if life isn't going well
it's not the universe that is preventing
you from having what you wish
it's your own developmental programming
all of my personal suffering was within
my own control
i needed to start controlling the
meaning i was giving the experiences of
life every thought you think
and every word you speak is a blueprint
that your mind body and psyche must it
has no choice work to make real
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how you
can change your subconscious mind
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one make different choices with dr joe
dispenza when you have an emotional
reaction to someone or something most
people think that they can't control
their emotional reaction
well it turns out if you allow that
emotional reaction it's called a
refractory period to last for hours or
days
that's called the mood
say to someone hey what's up he said i'm
in a mood why are you in a mood well i
had this thing happen to me five days
ago and i'm having one long emotional
reaction
if you keep that same emotional reaction
going on for weeks or months that's
called temperament
why is he so bitter i don't know let's
ask him why is he so bitter why are you
bitter well i had this thing happen to
me nine months ago
and if you keep that same emotional
reaction going on for years on end
that's called a personality trait
and so learning how to shorten your
refractory period of emotional reactions
is really where the work starts
so then
people when they have an event what they
do is they keep recalling the event
because the emotions of stress hormones
their survival emotions are saying pay
attention to what happened
because you want to be prepared if it
happens again turns out most people
spend 70 percent of their life
living in survival and living in stress
so they're they're always anticipating
the worst case scenario based on a past
experience and they're literally
out of the infinite potentials in the
quantum field they're selecting the
worst possible outcome and they're
beginning to emotionally embrace it with
fear and they're conditioning their body
into a state of fear do that enough
times
body has a panic attack without you you
can't even predict it because it's
programmed subconsciously
so then
you say to the person why are you this
way
and they'll say i am this way because of
this event that happened to me 15 or 20
years ago and what that means from
biological standpoint is that they
haven't been able to change since that
event
so then the emotions from the experience
tend to give the body and the brain a
rush of energy
so people become addicted to the rush of
those emotions and they use the problems
and conditions in their life to reaffirm
their limitation so at least they can
feel something so now when it comes time
to change you say the person why are you
this way well every time they recall the
event they're producing the same
chemistry in their brain and body as if
the event is occurring firing and wiring
the same circuits
and sending the same emotional signature
to the body well what's the relevance
behind that well your body is the
unconscious mind it doesn't know the
difference between the experience that's
creating the emotion and the emotion
that you're creating by thought alone so
the body's believing
is living in the same past experience 24
hours a day 7 days a week 365 days a
year
and so then when those emotions
influence certain thoughts and they do
and then those thoughts create the same
emotions and those same emotions
influence the same thoughts now the
entire person's state of being is in the
past
so then
the hardest part about change
is not making the same choice as you did
the day before period
and the moment you decide to make a
different choice get ready because it's
going to feel uncomfortable rule number
two be consistent with nicole lapera why
small promises why five breaths why not
an hour of uh you know breathing from
your belly what what's the idea behind
those little promises yeah thank you for
for highlighting that and for for asking
this question and it goes back to that
subconscious and its desire to remain in
that familiar so we create another
situation of overwhelm for ourselves
those of us who decide that starting
tomorrow
my life will be different from top to
bottom and maybe i have five new ten new
things on my to-do list i'm diving into
that deep end i'm telling my
subconscious that wow my life's gonna do
a you know 360 180 by tomorrow i'm
probably going to overwhelm so the way
we begin to build and create change
what's important is not five new things
for as long as i can white knuckle it
what's important is one new thing
from now until forever that consistency
of the habit so we want to make a small
promise we're already going to be
uncomfortable i talk about this a lot
too a concept that i call resistance
because every time we set an intention
to change even if logically you can have
as many of us do a court case for why i
really need to stick to this change this
time
right when i go to either the first time
i go to do the new thing or maybe it's
the fifth time that i'm trying to now
maintain my habit it's only a matter of
time before one of two things happen we
either get mental resistance in our mind
and our thoughts that could look like
the endless to-do list of other things
that we should be doing or maybe the
million reasons why this won't work this
time
or some of it drops into our bodies
where we just start to feel agitated or
just different than we normally feel and
before long
one of those two reasons can convince us
back into that familiar rut before long
i go back to being as i normally
am so the way we want to create and
maintain change is acknowledge that
discomfort is part of changing it's part
of doing something new it's that
unfamiliar space that my subconscious
likes to avoid we can even reframe it
it's signs that i'm moving in a
direction of difference how great so
don't expect it not to be there and then
we learn to work with it we integrate it
in a sense by making one small promise
and we focus on keeping it rule number
three align your subconscious and
conscious mind with john ashraf what do
you need to do at the conscious level in
order to get the subconscious aligned
when you're making a decision
you're using your conscious brain so
let's say you make a decision you know i
want to write a book i'd like to share
my life story i want to share my
my passion my interest my lessons uh
what's worked what hasn't worked and
there's something within me that wants
to share right and the reason i write by
books i want to share i want to share
what's worked what hasn't worked and why
um so what happens if you make a
conscious decision
but at the subconscious level
you have
um
a disempowering belief for example so
let's say your conscious decisions i
want to write a book i want to share my
knowledge and skills with the world but
underneath the surface
you have this belief this implicit
belief that well who am i to write a
book
what do you think is going to happen if
you have this conscious decision but a
subconscious belief
that
maybe you're not smart enough or worthy
enough to write a book who are you right
what do you think happens when
that goes on in your brain and let me
let me just look at the comments so give
me a comment what do you think happens
you know the goal
that excites you to write a book or to
do anything
um is going to release dopamine in your
brain make you feel good you might even
share it with your um your best friend
your family your husband your wife your
children i want to write a book
but what do you think is going to happen
if in the back of your
mind in the recesses of your brain
you've got a party that says but who are
you to write a book let's say you have a
job right now and maybe you're happy
fulfilled maybe you're not
and you say you know i'd really like to
start my own business i want to be my
own boss i want to have my own hours and
i want to work 80 hours um
to make less than i do in a full-time
job because i want to work for myself
well what if you know in the back
subconscious part of your brain
um there's a little voice that says um
oh what if you fail
what if you
um don't earn enough income to take care
of yourself your family the things that
you want to do
what if
it takes longer than you anticipate
so can you see how
these conscious decisions part of what
our brain is wired to these make
decisions
are backed in many instances
with a subconscious mind that is going
to hold us back unless we understand how
to get
our brain to work
in coherence so in addition to your
conscious
decision-making wanting
brain
if you don't understand
the power of the subconscious which is
uh driving 95
plus
percentage of your decisions and your
emotions
chances are you may be having one foot
on the on the gas and another foot on
the brake so the conscious and
subconscious divide
is really really really important when
you have a conscious goal
but you have subconscious patterns like
disempowering beliefs
uh i'm not good enough i'm not smart
enough i'm too young i'm too old you're
gonna have something that we know is
neural chaos there's a part of the brain
that wants the goal in the dream but
another part of the brain
that is going to fight you that's neural
chaos and a brain and chaos will almost
always divert back to its current
comfort zone
so if you have limiting beliefs
then you have to learn
how to get rid of your limiting belief
you decide you want to achieve a goal
but there's a feeling that you have a
belief that you have that you're not
um
good enough and
regardless of where you developed
that belief that you're not good enough
that is part of your subconscious mind
so
when you repeat the
thought
when you repeat the emotion and when you
don't follow through
with the behaviors necessary to achieve
a goal that you want to achieve
you reinforce
that neural pattern in the brain right
and a belief is nothing more than cells
that have connected that have been
reinforced
a belief is nothing more than neurons
cells that have created through
something called dendrite spiny
protuberances the little pieces on the
end that come together and connect those
are dendrites spiny protuberances
um dsps they're called and when they
form and reinforce the beliefs then
drive perception behaviors emotions etc
so when you have a belief that you know
is a disempowering one at the
subconscious level
here is a really easy first step trick
okay
take that belief write it down except i
want you to do this in a slightly
different way and i want you to do this
because here's what what we know about
the subconscious mind your brain doesn't
know some uh the difference between
something real or imagined
uh and so
what i want you to do grace and for
every one of you that wrote down a a
belief that you have that's
disempowering you is put in the past i
used to believe that i wasn't good
enough in the past i used to believe
that i wasn't smart enough in the past i
used to believe
fill in whatever the belief was and now
i'm learning how to feel and be more
than smart enough to achieve my goals so
all you're doing
right a lot of people will teach
um you know if you have a belief that
says you know i'm i'm not good enough
i'm not smart enough uh because i'm too
young because i'm too old because i'm
too asian or caucasian or too tall or
too short i can't
but if you take that same belief because
when you when you use language patterns
that are certainty based language
pattern which means i'm certain about
this uh this is the truth
right and then you say okay
in the past i used to believe this is
true and now i'm learning how and you
write the opposite of that what you're
doing in the brain
is instead of saying i am smart
and your brain says no you're not i am
good enough and your brain says no i'm
not you give yourself a bridge between
the two
and this little
inner size using self-talk is in the
past i used to believe this and now i'm
learning how now i'm discovering now i'm
moving towards being smart enough being
good enough being worthy enough et
cetera then your brain goes oh okay
let me help you find ways to do that hey
this is john asref and do you love good
books i love to read because there's so
much wisdom in books
you get to take somebody else's
knowledge skills research pay 15 20
bucks and you learn
so much now i'm reading this
awesome book called built to serve
find your purpose and become the leader
you were born to be and one of my new
friends really smart guy really great
guy who serves a lot of people evan
carmichael
wrote it and um
i'm gonna read a little bit from
chapter number one
and um i love this piece and maybe it's
because i just watched uh the series on
tv on michael jordan the last dance
which is really great by the way also
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan
talent
at something
everybody has a michael jordan talent at
something you just haven't found it yet
or
you have and you don't believe in
yourself enough to go all in
to go all in right
and you're a genius i believe you're a
genius and so does he
you're amazing you were not meant to
live a photocopy of someone else's life
you were not created to wake up and do
work that is below your capabilities you
have michael jordan level talent at
something and you need to uncover
exactly what your purpose is and how you
can serve and use the serve so
lots of pearls and gems and motivational
pieces
pick up built to serve evan carmichael
rising star
rule number four reprogram yourself with
bruce lipton bill is a friend like
you've had in your past hi tanya what a
pretty kitty cat you have
a friend that you've been very close to
like bill you know his behavior very
very well hey
jenny hi
see you later
and so not only do you know your
friend's behavior but in this particular
case you know your friend's parent so
bill
you find out is just like his parents
sometimes
i'm so stupid i can't do anything right
bill is a happy-go-lucky guy most of the
time but every now and then he stumbles
[Music]
and when he does so he gets very upset
oh i'm so stupid i can't do anything
right
oh
and the behavior express is not the
behavior that we know of built
oh okay
hi alex when you see bill behaving like
his father it excites you and you can't
wait to tell bill and you say
hey bill you're just like your dad
then you back away from bill i i'm not
like my dad i'm i'm nothing like my dad
huh how could you say i'm like my dad
i'm not i'm not my dad no
i'm not like him and bill gets so upset
and screams out how how can you compare
me to my father i am nothing like my
father
we've all seen that
we all laughed over it
but it has a very profound story
and the story is simply this we have
been programmed during our development
by our parents and in that process we
acquire their behaviors and the
unfortunate part about this is that
these behaviors are in our subconscious
mind and we don't see them what's
interesting
bill gets all excited and upset that you
compare him to his father and guess what
he is just like his father but there's a
profound point to this story everyone
else can see that bill looks like his
father it's only bill who doesn't see
this well this is more than just an
interesting story because the profound
point is bill's behavior is not exactly
what bill thinks it is every now and
then he comes out with his father's less
than good behavior and i say well why is
this relevant
well
because another profound point of this
story
we
are all bill
meaning
every day just like bill
we are playing programs and just like
bill we can't see them and i say why is
this relevant
because if we're playing subconscious
programs that we can't see then by
definition we are sabotaging our lives
and yet we can see we are the ones that
are sabotaging it so when things don't
go right we generally look up and say oh
it's not in my fate to have something
wonderful oh it's not in the cards oh
the universe is not supporting me and we
start to see ourselves as victims of
life out of control and we start blaming
everything and everyone around us for
the failures that we are experiencing
and yet the most important insight is
this the problem isn't on the outside
the problem as we just revealed with
bill is on the inside all of us like
bill have programs that we can't see
when we play them about 70 of the
programs we downloaded by a7 are
negative disempowering and
self-sabotaging and yet their
subconscious programs the significant
point is
subconscious programs means programs
below the level of consciousness
so all of us like bill
during the day start playing programs
from the background and training that we
receive from our own parents
significance if life isn't going well
it's not the universe that is preventing
you from having what you wish
it's your own developmental programming
and why this is so important is because
if we can see where we're struggling in
life we can also recognize
this is where an invisible program in
our subconscious is taking us off of our
track
significance is simply this
anything in your life that you desire
but you have to work hard for struggle
over sweat over put a lot of effort into
it a big question why are you working so
hard to get to that destination
the big answer
is because unconsciously you're playing
programs that you downloaded from your
family and your community that are
sabotaging you and just like bill you're
playing these programs and you can't see
them all you see is the result of a
negative program you do not see
how much you are creating that program
so it's important for us to step back at
this time and recognize
when we struggle to obtain our wishes
and desires
it's not an issue from outside control
it's an issue of inside programming
and once you know this
we are free to change that programming
and when we change that programming we
become empowered because with new
programs we can program success
happiness health and love rule number
five create new patterns with garen
jones when i was at rock bottom i didn't
know that i was at rock bottom and you
can't really change what you're not
aware of
and so it was like one of those things
where it's like can it get any worse bam
can it get any worse bam and it just i
kept asking the question
can it get any worse
i didn't know that what i was asking was
causing my life so it was to the point
where
either i die or i do something about it
because it was like i i didn't have my
my my daughter pretty much was like
you're not my father you don't know what
love is my girlfriend just broke up with
me
and you know my mother was pretty much
she had 16 different um
what's it called me she was on 16
different medications there was so much
stuff
going on
and i'm watching all of these people be
successful and i'm like
i'm more talented than them and i don't
understand
why i'm still in the exact same spot
which i didn't know was rock bottom
and then it one day it just all came
crashing down
and i was like
why am i here i remember lying down in
the middle of the road and i'm like i
want to die like right now and i stayed
there cars were driving by honking and
everything
and
i don't know what happened in between
that
but literally my car had just got out of
the impound my mom had paid for it she
didn't have much money but
somehow she would always do something
for her baby boy and she got my she got
my car to the impound the day i got my
car out of the impound
that's when somebody broke into my car
like and it was like can it get any
worse
that night on la brea on the corner of
la brea and hollywood
i'm at the there's like this like little
shopping center and i my car was parked
my window was busted out to the right
and
and
literally it was raining it was 3 43 in
the morning august 2011.
and it was
i yelled out eyes bloodshot red
and i still didn't know that this was
rock bottom but i've always focused on
what i don't want and i just remember
saying okay
okay i'm tired of fighting
i don't want to fight anymore
i want to be healthy
i want to be happy i want to be
surrounded by nothing but positive
people i just i just want to inspire
people and i want to make a bunch of
money but i want the money to represent
something that i passionately believe in
just show me a sign
show me a sign show me and i just kept
saying it over and over and over it
wasn't until a week later
until i the i met the the man at the gas
station and he asked me for money and he
said he said do you have any money she's
like it was a homeless guy
and he had a lot of money i said you
have more money than me
and he goes if you ever seen the movie
rain man the guy was talking to himself
person did the exact same thing it was
like change your mindset change your
life change your mindset change your
life change your minds to change your
life change your mindset and then they
walked away and it was in that very
moment
i felt like my whole entire life
was a lie i started with just
daily things just doing the opposite of
everything i would normally do i was
just opposite opposite opposite opposite
but that became my new pattern so it was
easy to make different decisions with
the same circumstances when i had
already built the muscle of doing the
opposite and that's how i even got into
this entire philosophy i stopped making
a left
so i stopped ended up ending up in
places where people who make a left end
and i turn the right whole different
direction whole different outcome met
new people different opportunities
everything
because it was an entire world i knew
nothing about i had no idea
that this world existed outside of
projects
outside of
um you know some of my friends with food
stamps outside of
um we can't afford it we can't afford it
we can't afford it if you think about
abc's the impact of abc's language
first there's gaga gugu then there's
language then there's the baby can now
say ball
now there's sentences
paragraphs
essays books
libraries
the impact of someone
growing up
in a struggled household where there's
fear base
insecurity base all of that that's a
form of language
most people don't know the language
outside of that because they stay inside
watch the same tv shows listen to the
same radio station hang around the same
friends never read books and just follow
wherever society says do this this is
popular
do this this is popular
but never really think for themselves
there is something inside of every child
and there's a desire to do something
but it gets lost
because you should do this you should go
to school and do this you should get a
good job you should do and all of a
sudden they'll go to whatever has energy
wherever the energy goes that's where
the energy flows
and
you know what i want what i would really
want them to know
is to tell themselves who they are like
i am powerful i am amazing and these are
things that i'm literally working with
with lots of parents now and they're
like yo within a week
he wasn't getting bullied no more she
wasn't she wasn't saying that she's ugly
anymore because she stopped listening to
the outside noise and she started
listening to what she told herself she
was rule number six change your beliefs
with david bayer i had to start figuring
out how to how to walk in the darkness
because that's kind of what it's like
what darkness what do you mean like
meaning when you're caught in this
psycho-cybernetic loop can you define
psycho-cybernetics yeah so
um it's this idea that um what you
believe
uh will dictate your thoughts on a
moment-by-moment basis so if you believe
that you know money's hard to make as a
simple example you're not going to have
ideas or thoughts around money that
would be
lending to making it easily right
uh and so so what you believe dictates
what you think you can't get like an
apple from an orange tree and what you
think you then experience is an emotion
right and then that emotion then
dictates what actions you do or do not
take and they're always aligned right
your beliefs dictate your thoughts
dictate your emotions dictate your
actions which produce your results and
your results when you look at them then
just reinforce the original belief
and so we're caught in that construct
right but the linchpin is the belief
system so the question is how do i
actually change what i believe if my
beliefs really do dictate my destiny
right which is i'm not the only person
suggesting that the question becomes how
do i change my beliefs and in that is is
an inherent challenge because by
definition beliefs are that which are
true
right for us
um and so then the question is how do we
break out of this
my way of breaking out of it was at one
point to understand and i'll start to
kind of walk you through the structure
of it
to understand that there were only two
states of emotional beingness that i
could be in at any given point in time
i would either be in a powerful state of
being states like joy curiosity
excitement calm peace
passion or i would be in a primal state
of being boredom anger frustration
some form of fear
i'm always in one of those two states
and i'm never in two states at one time
though those map beautifully to the
sympathetic nervous system and the
parasympathetic nervous system right so
in any moment we're either in fight or
flight or we're in rest and relaxation
through my journey what i realized was
the only cause of that switch to be
flipped was my own thinking
the meaning that i was giving the
experience the experience itself wasn't
dictating whether i was in a primal
state or a powerful state whether i was
in sympathetic fight-or-flight or
parasympathetic rest and rest and
restoration or relaxation it was the
meaning i was giving the experience and
so that meant that all of my personal
suffering was within my own control
i needed to start controlling the
meaning i was giving the experiences of
life
as we started doing this work early i
didn't see this initially in the work
that i was doing with myself but as we
started building a team of coaches and
as the coaches were coaching people what
we consistently saw was that the quality
of the thinking
that was causing people to move into a
primal state which was really the only
problem because when you're in a
powerful state you're connected to
creativity to inspiration to vitality to
energy health automatically operates
everything that we want is in a powerful
state of being when you're in a primal
state you don't have access to any of
that so when entrepreneurs say to me for
example what's the number one thing you
would suggest to grow my business i
would say notice by moment by moment
what state of being you're in and use
whatever tools or technologies you have
access to to move back into a powerful
state that's where things just unfold
and i'm not saying you don't have to
take consistent action and work your ass
off to create success but you do it from
a powerful state it's very hard to do it
from a primal state
and what we were seeing consistently was
that the quality of thinking that was
causing people to move into a primal
state when we really looked at it worked
with them around it was that 100 of the
time it was untrue
the only thing they were thinking they
were thinking was untrue i'm not good
enough i'm not smart enough i'm not good
enough i'm not smart enough there's not
enough time now we can start to talk
about like the larger metaphysical
philosophy behind all of this right uh
but i'll give you a prime example i was
working uh
personally coaching a 29 year old
egyptian muslim young man super
successful had his first multi-million
dollar business at 19 years old was
large running one of the largest
companies in this category at 29 years
old and i've been coaching him and he
was out one night in south beach with a
bunch of movers and shakers
and
vice president of the sports team number
one dj fashion designers whatever it was
he called me the next day and he said
listen i moved into a primal state last
night and i couldn't get out of it so i
need you to coach me on it because i
know his his vision for his life now the
most important thing for him is to
operate from a powerful state of being
i said okay so
what what happened he said well i was
there and i noticed that i started
having anxiety so i know i moved into a
primal state i said what'd you do next
he said i took a look at the thinking
that was causing it i said what did you
find he said i was thinking that i don't
belong here
i was like okay got it so then what did
you do and what we teach we teach a
couple of things but what we teach at
the highest level of this work is that
you're able to actually see the thinking
that's not true
is not true
and that's different than a lot of the
other
modalities i tried to use
to evolve
you can change your state
you can reframe something you can come
up with a better story
they're amazing tools out there like
breath work plant tech i mean there's a
bunch of stuff out there which we can
get into right hack yeah that's nice
there's a bunch of stuff out there right
but i'm we're very focused on the
personal technology not the third party
tools right but i've explored a lot of
them
so what we believe is the fastest way
for you to eradicate a limiting belief
is to actually see the limiting belief
is untrue the moment that happens
there's a reorganization in your brain
like you can't unsee it once you see the
lie is a lie
right there's a huge shift it reorients
you to the experiences of your life it
reorients you to you to money to
relationship so i said to him so what
happened when you saw that you were
thinking i don't belong here and he says
it seemed true
he goes now i knew it wasn't because he
bought in to what we teach
and i said okay great so i'll coach you
on it you know with coaching you have a
lot of leverage and you don't always
have to use a leverage i'm going to give
you an example of
but i knew he was a spiritual
his faith was very important to him so i
said let me ask you a question you
believe in god don't you he said yes i
said the omnipotent omniscient kind of
all-knowing type of god he goes
absolutely and i said then how did your
god put you in the wrong place on friday
night where you actually don't belong
and there was a pause and i heard him on
the other end of the line and he goes oh
my god and i said what is it he goes
i belong everywhere i am
that's a fundamental reorientation to
the experiences of your life
and what i believe is that's the deepest
most permanent fastest way to actually
move through
the crazy unreality that we've created
for ourselves as a result of adopting a
bunch of other crazy people's beliefs
when we were kids right to start
reconnecting with what's really true
and so in that moment of seeing that you
actually believe everywhere belong
everywhere that you are you move back
into a powerful state and now you're
moving forward with your life in a
powerful way rule number seven be clear
with marissa pierre when you're really
clear what you want and you make it
bigger brighter your mind's job is to go
after what you want
when you've looked at what you want the
biggest block is not that the biggest
block is this
deciding you're worth it that is the
biggest block 85 percent of success is
mindset mindset mine's only 15 is work
so if you have the mindset i want it i
deserve it i'm gonna have this nothing
is going to stop me when someone said to
naomi campbell naomi
you'll never be on the cover of dope
vogue that door is shut off shut i'll
kick it open and she would too and i
love that about her shut the door to
black girls on the cover of like no no
no i'm going to kick that door down
so that's that i'm worth it oh it's shut
well maybe i can go on the cover of
someone else maybe cosmopolitan no you
have to
really believe you're worth it and the
biggest block to success is not not
having opportunities it's having a
i don't think i'm worth it i i really
like that person but what if they reject
me i really want a career but what if
i've do you know 70 percent of lottery
was an amazing statistic are completely
bankrupt
in three years you know why because they
don't believe that i've got all this
money i feel kind of embarrassed i've
worked with a lot and they say oh you
know i felt really uncomfortable i had
all this money i go to the pub with my
friends and if i put my hand in my
pocket there you go showing off again
but if i didn't they go well
you have all this we've got to pay for
our own drinks you're a
multi-millionaire
and and the feeling of i don't deserve
this you know amy winehouse was a really
interesting girl because she'd always i
don't deserve this success i just wrote
a song in five minutes and
i don't understand how i've got all this
money and it's what i call the self
destructive sound if you believe you're
not worth it only will you not get it if
you get it you'll get rid of it as fast
as you possibly can your self-destruct
you'll procrastinate
and i see that with many many rock stars
who make so much money
all saints did that at the end of their
thing they had no money how can you have
no money i don't know i just gave it all
to everyone else why because i didn't
ever really think i was worth it
and i created the i'm enough movement
because i'd see person
after person after person also the same
thing
yeah i've got this but i don't feel
worthy of it so the biggest thing is you
must decide i'm worth it i'm worthy of
love i'm worthy i'm worthy of fame i'm
worthy of whatever you want it can be
anything but you've got to believe
you're worth it and that probably really
should be the first step so let's turn
this around your first step whatever you
want is to just say
i'm worth it it's not hard work you're
just wondering going i'm worth it
the most successful advert in the whole
world is that l'oreal i'm working so i'm
going to wear the cheap shampoo but hang
on a minute i want to be like jennifer
anderson if she's worth it i'm worth it
i'm buying that when i know in my head
it's not any better than that one but i
somehow believe i'm worth it
so if you can develop a worth it
mentality
and what does that mean it means you
look in there go i can have whatever i
want with bells and if i want it i'm
worth it i want this amazing person i'm
worth it i want to have
great kids that are amazing i'm worth it
i want an incredible business that
knocks everyone else out of the park i
want to be the best well believe you're
worth it
i a lot of olympic athletes never go hey
i'm okay being silver i don't mind but i
just don't mind even coming i want to be
i want to be gold
if you want to be gold you've got to
believe you're worth it because that
belief you're worth it gets you out of
bed in the snow
and makes you train one of the most
vexing things about the mind is cool
really is that it only likes what it
already knows we are hardwired to run
back to what is familiar
and to run away from what is
unfortunately who here has children i
know you have
how many notices when there were two i
don't want that i don't i only like
strawberry yogurt in a blue bowl and
that's yellow yogurt or i don't want it
what kept children alive when they got
to age two and they could wander around
and eat their own stuff is only eating
what they already knew i like that
cereal i like those chicken nuggets i
like everything with ketchup
if i don't know know it i'm not gonna
have it when you're going to go oh i see
you just you don't know this this is not
familiar you know i took my daughter a
great expense to finland to meet father
christmas and she spent the whole time
watching the little mermaid and finish
i'm like but i understood that she'd
watched it a hundred times she
understood everything they were saying
in finnish she's like i want to sit here
and watch a little mermaid in finnish
because i already know it
and so
your mind job is to keep you alive and
it's always working out what causes you
pleasure and what causes you pain and
when it know what causes you pain when
it knows it will move you away from it
forever when people say you know what
if i get dumped by one more guy if i get
ghosted again that's it i'm just going
to jump under a train nobody means that
when you say
if i have to deal with one more castle
i'm going to kill myself
one more commute on that 405 freeway in
la and that's it i'm just gonna
take an overdose we say all these crazy
things i mean i live in l.a people say
every day i'm i'm going to lose my [ __ ]
now like why would you even say that
that's such a stupid thing to say
if you understand how the mind works
because every thought you think
and every word you speak is a blueprint
that your mind body and psyche must it
has no choice work to make real
so if you start from there because it is
to every thought i think
and every word i speak is a blueprint
that my mind and body are making real so
when you say i really want to have this
but i don't know where to start and it's
so confusing and i'm a bit lost here
your mind stays if you say i've got a
story it's an amazing story the world is
desperate for my story and i know how to
deliver it even if you don't i know
it's all coming to me
you'll find you wake up thinking i know
what to do
because when you speak and it's the
blueprint your mind moves you towards it
rule number eight become aware with don
dapani every time the awareness goes
into the future starts thinking of a
hurdle bring awareness back and say i am
not going to go there
right i am not going to go there because
if you're aware awareness goes that's
where energy flows so every time you
think of a hurdle you're putting energy
into that hurdle
right so bring awareness back and say i
don't want to go there and then tell
yourself i will do what i will to do and
that's a beautiful information you can
say for yourself
what is it
i will do what i will to do exactly and
i will be what i will to be
and just say that every morning when you
wake up and every night before you go to
bed the best time to program your
subconscious mind is right when you wake
up and right when you before you go to
sleep because as you wake up and before
you go to sleep your conscious mind is
dull you know how you wake up and you're
kind of groggy and you're like what day
is it where am i right
that's
the best time to impress the
subconscious right have you ever woken
up and heard some music and then all day
that music's playing in your head
have you ever had that experience right
that's because when you're waking up
your conscious mind is groggy and
unfortunately miley cyrus is on and it
programs your subconscious and then all
day is
playing miley cyrus in your head right
so best time to do affirmation is when
your conscious mind is dull and that's
when you wake up and when you
go to sleep because that's when you're
groggy another great time when is
another great time is when your
conscious mind is dull
do you know
when you're drunk
all right
when you drunk your conscious mind gets
dull your subconscious becomes the
dominant mind that's why someone when
they're drunk and going like that's an
ugly sweater i'm so sorry i didn't mean
to say that
right
because the subconscious comes dominant
right
so when you drink your conscious mind
gets dull the subconscious becomes
dormant it's a lovely sweater by the way
i was just giving you an example right
the subconscious mind becomes dominant
and i see in london that people are
really trying to dull their conscious
mind rule number nine envision your
dream with manny coachman i always knew
like anything i'm doing early on is a
stepping stone you know with that
mentality i had a you know i had a much
bigger picture in my mind you know i
wanted to be a multi-millionaire i
wanted to own a bunch of exotic cars a
big mansion as a matter of fact at age
15 or 16 i have to go find a picture i
drew a mansion with some palm trees in
front of it and
two mercedes back then i didn't know
what the ferrari is or lamborghini yeah
i knew mercedes right yeah so i i drew
two convertible mercedes with palm trees
and i have to find that it's somewhere
in my attic probably that is on but so
you know
you envision your dream where you want
to be and then your subconscious will
take over if you're you know if you
really put the effort your subconscious
will do the rest they will figure out
the how yeah it's kind of like pouring
water on top of the mountain it'll find
a way to get down right it may go
straight you may go turn left you got to
pour the water you got to pour the water
and most people don't huh and to pour
the water you got to climb the mountain
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is visualize
with brian tracy there are four parts of
visualization that you can learn and
practice to assure that you use this
incredible power to its best advantage
all the days of your life now the first
aspect of visualization is called
frequency
this refers to the number of times that
you visualize a particular goal as
achieved
of yourself performing in an excellent
way in a particular event or
circumstance
circumstance
repeat a clear mental picture of your
very best performance or result the more
rapidly it will appear
as part of your reality
the second element of visualization is
the duration of the mental image
the length of time that you can hold the
picture in your mind each time you
replay it
when you deeply relax you can often hold
a mental picture of yourself performing
at your best for several seconds and
then longer for several minutes the
longer you can hold your mental picture
the more deeply it will be impressed
into your subconscious mind and the more
rapidly it will express itself in your
subsequent performance
the third element of visualization is
vividness
there seems to be a direct relationship
between how clearly you can see your
desired goal or result in your mind and
how quickly it comes into your reality
this element of visualization is what
explains the powers of the law of
attraction and the law of correspondence
the vividness of your desire directly
determines how quickly it materializes
in the world around you
now here's an interesting point when you
set a new goal for yourself your image
or picture of this goal will usually be
vague and fuzzy
but the more often you write it and
review it and repeat it mentally the
clearer it becomes for you
eventually it becomes crystal clear
at that point the goal will suddenly
appear in your world exactly as you
imagined it
now the fourth element of visualization
is intensity
the amount of emotion that you attach to
your visual image
in reality this is the most important
and powerful part of the visualization
process
sometimes if your emotion is intense
enough and your visual image is clear
enough your goal will immediately come
true
of course the elements of frequency
duration
vividness and intensity can help you or
hurt you
like nature the power of visualization
is neutral
like a two-edged sword you can cut in
either direction it can either make you
a success
or make you a failure
visualization brings you whatever you
vividly and intensely imagine
whether good or bad
continually feed your mind with clear
exciting emotional pictures remember
your imagination is your preview of
life's coming attractions now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch a video and just get motivated you
have a 35 chance of actually following
through that's what the science says and
that is not good enough believe nation
we need to do better when you actually
get motivated and then create a specific
plan of action for what you're going to
do this week you have a 91 chance of
following through and when you publicly
commit to somebody else like leaving a
comment below on this video it jumps
even higher so i want that for you i
want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week so i can
celebrate with you
are we able to go 100 in into 100
power of our own brain the seed of the
mind we are i went into the deepest i
activated it while being stressfully
exposed to ice water on the skin and
normally you cannot do nothing
there's no breathing in the brain scan
you cannot move it's nothing only you
can use the power of your own brain of
your mind
and it showed i was making the skin
temperature not going down while being
exposed to ice water
so then they looked inside the brain
and then they saw on the surface the
thinking brain the prefrontal cortex the
conscious brain
our thought thinking brain
go into the deepest part of the brain
and robustly activating so the if you
are able to go into the deepest
then you have done them all you can go
anywhere
and that is now the question we are on
the threshold of the power of the mind
being accessible for every human in the
world
when the first time people broke the
record
by going
below
10 seconds the next year 15 people could
do it it's morphology
we are connected we only need to have
this conviction now
and this belief
based on signs
hey guys
you are able to take over the power of
your own brain
it's here
just invest into that and not invest in
to not being able to do that we become
immortal by understanding through the
power of our own brain to connect with
the soul
and because that sounds like hippie
[ __ ]
that's why i go through science right i
take the brain surgeons i take the
neurologists the
immunologists the biochemical professors
and
hey i challenge any scientist in the
world prove me wrong yeah i think that
we are here here on this earth
to prove that the soul is able to go
through our conscious brain
and become manifested
and uh
that is the core if we stay at the core
we grow into it but no this world is
about now you got to serve the system
you got to serve the system who creates
wars and stress and diseases and things
that is normal and we cannot do anything
no we can do all we can bring peace and
power to ourselves to become happy
strong and healthy and with that the
purpose of our lives the soul itself
[Music]
if you want to get some affirmations for
success to control your subconscious
mind check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i think that science really is the
language that does that really well and
and the new sciences like quantum
physics and uh neuroplasticity
neuroscience neuro endocrinology you
know